[Music]
well you don't have you get full brain
on reboot of a movie based off a board
game what are you picking a Hungry
Hungry Hippos with the [ __ ]
fantastic all mothers honor - I fail
ghost - I'm very hungry here both but
it's a horse there are very tough to be
her terrifying hippo cannibals I have to
begin to make based off a true story and
a board game
it's Hungry Hungry Hippos starring Bryan
Callen yeah I wanna be a hungry hippo no
no you're the [ __ ] hippo you ask that
the hippos are trying to eat ah you're
the badass you're the Chris Pratt
character yes like lost world perhaps a
little better-looking and taller than I
am
you're the can you cast you yeah you got
the gig [ __ ] reaiiy the Mita I'm gonna
be the voice of the bird that cleans
their mouths yes the bird look clean is
that like a boy experience oh you're the
bird you're the star and I'm with
crocodile in the water
where I get I clean up the scraps in
which it was my mother which is a mama
I'm a heroine so I gotta yeah yeah I'm
the brains of the operation hippos kind
of hippos stupid I'm kind of organized
I'm like laughing weird zero he's not
very good avoid us I don't do
impressions come on try be just like
this step out your bad night can I be an
Asian crocodile no my hippo no because
that tell something that's super like
why offensive I thought I thought don't
really know we're cool trust no sir
we're not we're you can't I'm an Asian
closet area typical offensive Asian
impression that was around in the 60s to
be clear it doesn't mean that Asian
crocodiles speak Chinese that that's
Dianetics English you says a little
Chinese swing so did you wear all nickel
really short no oh
licorice tips no they said I say make a
well just do I kill the guys before I
send the hippos on we'll all to go with
you're saying licorice don't say make a
wish wow-whee I want to apologize your
job stirred by the Klan that really is
what we're being funded Roz Roz
everywhere Rock You by white supremacy
layup gentlemen hey my [ __ ] movie mom
whoo it's my movie
[Music]